[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who gets away
with mordor in this video we're breaking
down rings of power episode three after
everyone loved our last breakdown i
loved it i thought i thought we'd dive
back into the show for everyone who's
still watching to bring you everything
you need to know about the characters
callbacks and our thoughts on the entry
however if a character pops up in the
main lord of the rings film series then
i think that they're fair game to talk
about so check out now if you don't want
those connections confirmed this is
mainly referring to alindial and asildor
who we already see what happens to in
the fellowship of the rings super long
disclaimer but yeah you've just got to
preface the video with that before we
dive into it without the way thanks for
clicking the video now let's get into
the rings of power
[Music]
now this episode is called adar which is
the name of a corrupted elvish warlord
who has been described as being one of
the main antagonists of this series he
pops up at the end of the entry and he's
played by another game of thrones alumni
in joseph mall so far we've got young
ned stark uncle ben not that one and old
ned stark all being tied to lord of the
rings stuff my brain is [ __ ] from the
lore of these two series and at this
point i feel like they've replaced the
memories of my family even my beloved
uncle damon
was it dame i think his name was damon
what now both episode one and two were
kind of absent of villains other than
the ones that we saw briefly like sauron
edar is a completely new character for
the show and a corrupted elf it's an
interesting way to take things that we
haven't really seen before this entry
opens with an orc saying for ada and
this is brought full circle by his
introduction at the end elves are
usually on the side of gerd but there
are some that ended up committing bad
acts which has been seen in a number of
characters banor ended up attacking
elves in an event known as the kin
slaying which may have been teased at in
episode 1. now that took place in the
silmarillion and as many of you pointed
out in our last video amazon doesn't
actually own the rights to that huge
apologies for saying that they did and i
kind of got a bit lost in the rights
issue stuff as it's all a lot of legal
babble that i still don't fully get now
last episode saw elrond invoking the
right of sigan turag in kazadoom the
stranger pointed out a constellation
tinori that he made with fireflies and
bronwyn's village packed up and left due
to orcs starting to show up in the area
huge head outs to eric boswell pointing
out that the map regions that we see in
the southlands actually also have a
mountain range that resembles what would
later become model when we later see a
map of the area we can catch the same
landmarks there which lines up with the
evil lance this means that we could end
up seeing the formation of the region
throughout this series amazon has said
that they plan to do five seasons with
the creative team saying that they
already know what the final shot will be
in the final episode now we begin with
the rendezer being dragged through a
dog's stronghold his opening is a bit
trippy with the camera being blurred to
convey his state of being knocked out i
kind of hate when shows and movies do
stuff like this and to be honest i kind
of found the arandia stuff a bit weak in
this entry i get the creative choice
behind this as we do end the entry with
this blair returning in order to tease
the villain but yeah it's just a bit of
a weird way to open the episode a win is
a door not a door when it's a jaw and
that's why we get eight thousand
dislikes thanks a lot you chumps now
there are a couple of important details
here such as the cloths that hang over
the orcs hideout and these help to block
out the sun last week we saw that the
orc who attacked bronwyn had lots of
burn marks all over its body and here we
watch as the sun scalds their skin
almost like they're vampires this is why
saruman red the urukai because they were
able to move during the daylight making
them far more formidable they've also
kept things in line with the way that
peter jackson presented them with the
orcs carrying carrying cockney accents
this one reminded me a lot of the one
from the two towers and i feel like both
the design and voice overs were meant to
be similar to echo that cut across to
galadriel who hears the screams of the
elves and as we saw in the fellowship
she did possess somewhat psychic powers
galadriel was able to communicate
telepathically with a fellowship and she
could also sense when frodo was coming
due to him bringing great evil through
the ring everyone calls her a mary sue
and i have no idea who that is but maybe
people are just jealous of mary sue
because it sounds like she's great at
everything i haven't
anyway she shacked it with hal rand who
we learn a lot more about in this entry
i want to talk about in more in detail
when we get to that part of the episode
but it is starting to seem likely that
he might be theo's father we discover
that he comes from the southlands and
that he was driven away from his home
this is also something that theo brought
up when discussing his father and hal
brand likely ushers in the new king
however as we know from the law several
of the king's men were corrupted by
sauron and they were turned into ring
wraiths i'm still holding strong on the
theory that hal bran will end up
becoming the witch king and that his
character rock throughout the five
seasons will follow him as he rises up
and gets corrupted traveling out on the
belt we also meet el indial and later
his son is sildore you'll likely know
these names from the book and movie
trilogy with them being extremely
important in the first battle against
sauron alindale ended up becoming the
king of honor and gondola and he also
gained the title of high king of dundeen
is it dundeen or dundain anyway moving
on known as a great warrior he fought
alongside gil galad in the first battle
that opens up the fellowship in that
scene we saw as he was struck down by
sauron and his son a seal door then
rushed to his side he ended up seemingly
defeating the villain but due to him
being unwilling to toss the ring into
mount doom the evil was allowed to live
on the reasons for this will likely be
explored in the series with numenor
taking a big focus as to why he wants to
hold on to all the power that he ends up
having the seal door was later killed
when he was attacked by orcs and he
ended up losing the ring which we then
betrayed him i feel like the entire show
will likely build up towards the battle
at the sort of fellowship with all these
key characters falling into place
throughout the entire series the show is
having to condense a lot of characters
and timelines together due to the elves
living such long lifetimes and if they
actually did the series in the time
frame the books take place in then we'd
have to change the human characters out
every week because they'd be dead like
my enthusiasm is right now now we also
meet his daughter and isilda's sister
she never featured in the original work
and instead the focus was put on his
brother who i don't know if they're
actually going to be appearing in the
series in the original work this was a
character known as an aryan however the
series has changed things up and created
a completely new one in order to replace
her gonna go down well and when
discussing this with looper emma hovart
said her name is aryan she's the baby of
the family i think she was created
because the schism that happens on the
island also needs to be reflected within
the family she serves a plot function in
that sense and she also replaces the
feminine hole that's been left by the
loss of their mother at least she's
trying her hottest this season to be as
much of a mother as she can to her very
troubled brother so yeah lots of things
going on with her and numenor is also a
very important location that we visit in
the episode he watches the beacons light
up as the ship travels in and there's
also lots of cool details that we see on
this journey now this is an island
kingdom and we see what it looks like
later on when we travel from the
location to the southlands on the map as
you can see it sits in the sundering sea
surrounded by a vast ocean the city we
visit is actually almenolos or
armenilosa which is the capital of the
realm and it's where major parts of the
season will be taking place described as
being the greatest kingdom of men we
watch as there are giant heads serving
as tributes to the kings that have come
before you also see a massive one
pouring water down and huge head outs
tonight of the rings we're pointing out
that this may be valor ulna aka the lord
of waters though we don't get this fully
confirmed the statues we've seen of him
and are based on the books does best
some resemblance to him so i'm guessing
that it's him noodle rings definitely go
check them out now as they enter the
archway we can catch a sun symbol at the
top this is an emblem that appears on a
lot of things throughout the kingdom and
it's important to pay attention to it
now as they pull into the port we can
catch the holy mountain of numenor in
the background which is known as mount
menotomer this was devoted to the god
ilovator who we talked about in our
first breakdown he basically created the
universe in order and everything within
it birds didn't approach this mountain
except for eagles and these were seen as
the holy guardians of the shrine next to
him we can't catch a statue of arendell
who was actually elrond's father he was
also the father of elros aka elron's
brother and he's a very important
character in the law he was a half elvin
mariner who traveled to valinor and he
carried a star across the sky during the
first age helene deal of course sounds
very similar to his name and it means
the one who loves stars potentially
tying back to this it also means alfred
and we know that alindial does fight
side by side with them during the great
battle i think the statue is purposely
done like this to invoke images of the
organarth who we saw in the fellowship
of the rings interestingly his hand is
open and almost welcoming however the
organized were holding up an open palm
almost as if they were saying stop don't
come any closer you bastard now this
shows how the mindset of men changed
with them being welcoming initially but
after all the stuff that goes down in
newman or things end up changing the
entire kingdom is clearly a precursor to
ministerith with the main part being
very similar in design to how that great
city is laid out you of course have the
triangular walkway and this possesses a
white tree in the middle similar to how
it's laid out there known as nimloft
affair this grew in the king's court and
it descended from the great trees that
we saw in the intro last week the
sildore ended up taking a seedling from
it and this was replanted in
middle-earth its descendants were going
to be called the white trees of gondor
and it ties these kingdoms all together
now as you hear when their petals fall
it's seen as a bad omen ushering in a
great event early falling of course
happened with the arrival of the
stranger and it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme now one thing we missed last
week was that a reggian's ruins could
actually be seen in the fellowship again
tying these kingdoms and their lineage
to the main series as they walk through
the streets we learn some of the history
including how the men of numenor stood
with the elves whereas the southland
ones sided with morgoth we see the
difference in the locations with this
being a vast expansive kingdom whereas
the southlands are a shell just like
sunderland hey got him again i'm just
kidding probably moving there soon which
it's me bloody wife anyway the elves
gifted the new minorians his kingdom but
it didn't make the tensions any easier
similar to the dwarves the people are
still untrusting of the elves and as
mentioned in episode 2 the fact that
elves were immortal caused a number of
issues they weren't really able to build
relationships because they missed out on
a lot of big events such as birthdays
and also funerals don't want to spoil
what happens to this pair but they are
very important and they have their own
rivalry and quests for power if you pay
close attention to her you'll also
notice a symbol in the middle of her
chest and this appears in the titles
made out of the lines of sand really
nice touch having collateral listing off
her titles and this robs everyone the
wrong way even though hal brown could do
this due to what we later learn he
prefers to play certain situations to
his advantage by appearing humble so
that people drop their gods this is a
tactic he uses on a lindeal in order to
gain the two tree dagger and also later
at the bar these are people who don't
take kindly to him in these parts but he
gets them to drop their god by
pretending to be a grateful friend he
plays a situation well where she comes
in demanding rides and security and
they're clearly making her character
like this so she can learn how to deal
with people whilst avoiding
confrontation made to a three days which
collateral things could spell mount doom
for the southlands and she wants to get
out o'hal bran does a line about not
wanting to leap back into the furnace
and it might be a reach it might be but
i thought this was playing on the term
out of the frying pan into the fire this
was the name of the sixth chapter in the
hobbit book so i feel like the lines
were purposely put across like this
after meeting a seal door and his sister
i was thinking my man might end up doing
a jaime lannister cause god damn we cut
that cut
el indial is also forced by muriel to
perform a service for the realm and he's
sent to very much spying galadriel now
he ends up striking up a friendship with
her after showing he speaks elvish again
tying back to his nickname of alfred he
points out that the statues throughout
the city have elvish inscriptions on
them and these are somewhat reminiscent
of the tree carvings that appeared in
episode one the pair right out of the
hall of lauren horseback and you know
what it was really nice seeing galadriel
enjoying herself come on you caught you
couldn't hate that [ __ ] surely it was a
really beautiful beach scene
and it reminded me of a scottish widow
advert but yeah it was nice exploring
the island i wasn't crying there by the
way i promise
now back with the ronda we see as he's
reunited with the other two elves from
his patrol and we watch as they search
for what we're told is some sort of
weapon whilst we don't know what this is
it likely calls back to the play that
theo took with him last week we
discussed in our last video how it
reformed almost like a mogul blade being
dusted in reverse
this was seen when aragorn grabbed it
after frodo got stabbed and here we
watched his blood from theo reformed it
galadriel's company brought up the
unseen world in episode 1 and they
discussed how those at the mountain lair
had been experimenting with it those
stabbed by mogul blades were pulled into
the unseen world which is where frodo
started to go after being struck by it
so i think that the weapon is the sword
and it could be pulling them in or
pulling sauron out or maybe even morgoth
who knows initially they believe that
arda is an alias of sauron and it could
well be in the books he appeared in many
forms and he took the name anita which
translated a lot of gifts he ended up
befriending keller brimble and basically
led them on a path so that they could
create the rings this could sign to the
furnace plot with keller broomball and
due to there being several forms of the
character order could be one too i don't
really think that that's the case but i
thought i'd just touch upon it for a bit
due to the conversation that aaron dear
has they also talk about running for the
tree line when the sunlight hits but we
see how this fails come the end of the
entry you also have an awkward exchange
awkward with their captors and they're
given water which makes them lower their
guards so one can be killed lots of
slow-mo during this man i feel like
elves are always killed like this due to
their being endless peter jackson did it
a lot too but due to not really caring
about this character i didn't find it
that impactful now this death is all
started by them refusing to shift a tree
out the way and elves weren't on his big
preservers because they lived forever
well except for this guy they wanted to
keep things the same with very little
change this is why they went to the west
where they could be away from every
other race men were banned from there
because they lived short lives and
changed much whereas elves just wanted
to keep the status quo now aaron dear
eventually agrees to cut the tree down
and using a great axe he starts to take
it out at the toby gets a look at the no
man's land that they've created and this
resembles what saruman did with a forest
in two towers he faced the wrath of the
ends and we know from the end of episode
one that they're out in the world this
could possibly come into play down the
line but let me know below exactly how
you think he's gonna get out of this now
hal bran ends up trying to become a
blacksmith but he's rejected the boss is
the golden sigil on his top which we
learn is a gold crest and hal brown
manipulates the punners in the bar in
order to steal theirs this will allow
him to forge steal and gain a weapon now
there's a nice little detail you might
miss but when he's in the ball with them
standing up if you watch hal brand's
hand then you can see his arm reaching
around the guy's shoulder he then
unclips the crest and walks off with it
as he goes they did something similar
with a boat scene last week and you
could actually see him slowly pushing
away from the raft as the worm came in
really nice little scene that had me
chuckling and this then goes into the
typical back alley brawl that shows a
character knows how to handle themselves
i feel like they could have skipped this
but they're clearly showing that hal
bran is a skilled fighter it's a bit
cliche
the whole back alley thing but it sets
up that he's gonna be really deadly if
he gets a weapon he's caught by the gods
and they're all wearing golden armor
like what we first saw at the start of
fellowship of the rings back with
galadriel we watch as she draws sauron
symbol and discovers that this is
actually a map rather than it being a
sigil it once more confirms that the
enemy is in the southlands and that
their plan is to create a realm where
evil will thrive this was to be enacted
in the event of morgoth's defeat and in
the ashes mordor will rise now other
interesting details that happen here is
that elros himself assembled the hall of
law we also learned that because the
king was loyal to the elves that he was
cast out i think he'll likely be a
character that pops up in the series
although all this stuff was really
gripping and pulling out to see the map
revelation was a twist i don't think
anyone picked up on add me like i had
you looking in the wrong section how
could i be so stupid
wrong franchise now back with the half
foot we see them doing another slow
motion thing and it's basically a forest
ritual where they remember the fallen
they hammer home the idea that they are
safer together and as they don't have an
established home like the shire yet
they're constantly on the move due to
their size they're pretty weak and thus
they have to scavenge in order to
survive the weak are left behind and
though nori's family would struggle with
this the stranger ends up helping out
that's it
[Music]
okay so the stranger is called a
stranger because amazon want to keep his
true name a close guarded secret they've
created lots of original characters for
the series and therefore i think that he
ties into the greater lore now he could
be gandalf or saruman i think it would
cause too many issues with the fan base
they have enough as it is and wizards
typically came from the ocean with
saruman being the one who arrives first
and we haven't heard about him now there
are lots of ties to the stranger in fire
in episode one we watched as the company
of elves said that their torches didn't
give off any heat because of how evil it
was the lack of heat was also shown with
nori who said that the strangest
meteorite fire on the ground didn't give
off any heat either in fellowship
gandalf of course tossed the ring into
the fire at bilbo so that the
inscription could be red and he also
remarked on the item being quite cool
therefore this could be anita who we
talked about before and he could be
coming in under the guise of being a
friend probably probably gandalf though
isn't it
and that's in it people are going to go
wild but that's in the theory
might not be true
don't get angry because it's a theory
i'm telling you
an idiot
anyway logo says that if they're at the
front of the caravan then they'll be
okay but they're banished to the back
where they'll be easier for the wolves
to pick off also we said last week that
the creatures around them were wargs but
we actually meet one in this episode
whereas those wolves look like intel
dons the wargs are way closer to a dog
and they would like to be bred to become
even bigger and more fearsome nori 2
digs out maps for the constellation i
think it's all going to end with the
characters converging in the southlands
these are accidentally burned by the
stranger so they're gonna have to find
another way at night they pay respect to
the dead and there's lots of
similarities to bilbo's speech in the
fellowship of the ring these are the
names of all those who fell behind in
prior migrations and this death of
course causes worry for the brandy foots
among sees we hear several proud fellows
who died along the way and these are all
family members of poppy explaining why
she's alone you also hear phrases like
the tallest milkweed gets snipped which
is the middle earth version of the nail
that sticks up gets hammered down now
sildor sees his phrase in action too
after he tries to defer his duty to the
sea trial but his sister gets accepted
into the builder's guild galadriel
visits hal bran in jail and she brings
his sigil with him which confirms he was
the king of the southlands she noticed
this last week on the raft and we can
see why he's ashamed due to his
ancestors swearing an oath to morgoth
he's very much fitting the aragorn role
of being the reluctant king but he's
gonna have to do it because all the
other kings are gone [ __ ] hells
sorry about that you know what the
dislikes right there i'm not even mad
what do you mean you already hid it
now galadriel believes that it's fate
that the pair have been brought together
and that this union can finally unite
the elves and men against the greater
evil obviously we know this happens with
alien deal and a cell door but due to
hal bran being missing i do think there
will be more to him now we also see a
puppet show with a blonde head elf that
fights off an evil villain in order to
save the queen i don't know if this is
pulling from the extended lore as i
can't think of a time with this but it
might be referring to something in the
past i was thinking maybe luthien who
sang at morgoth but there wasn't a queen
involved and she had darker hair she did
appear in the tree carvings last week i
think the puppet show is more just a
prophecy with galadriel it likely spells
the big event that's coming with numenor
the stranger ends up helping the caravan
and the entry ends with aaron diaz plan
failing and we get the arrival of a doll
now as for my thoughts on the episode i
was a bit disappointed with how this
turned out bella in comparison to last
week that this was a step down that
unfortunately focused a bit too much on
world building again rather than getting
the plot moving we still don't really
have any idea where this series is going
outside of it building towards the big
battle with sauron and outside of
numenor and the hal bran revelation i
don't think this really had anything
that i'm to remember all that much this
time next week now because i said that i
enjoyed the first 15 minutes of episode
1 and the last 15 minutes of it and also
said that two was more consistent but
with less high moments i'm apparently a
paid a paid shill by amazon [ __ ] wish
i was me because i'd much rather be
chilling with bezos on an island
somewhere with my daughter rhaenyra
rather than doing this talking to you
your piece of sh i love you really but
honestly though i'm just not tied up
into the whole culture war thing because
i just don't care if you want to hear
people sitting on the show every week
then that's fine there's lots of great
channels out there right now dropping
videos made just for you i honestly try
and approach this stuff with an open
mind and offer positives and negatives
in my reviews because that's just what i
try to do now i did have comments saying
a shill for this in she-hulk to get
early access but if you've seen my
reviews on that show then you'll know i
haven't haven't exactly been singing its
praises now i know there will be some of
you out there that think i get paid for
reviews but unless i show you my bank
account there's absolutely no way to
prove that i think companies would
actually be much better off giving money
to channels that say everything is bad
instead of me and if there were studios
offering people money for reviews then
it 100 would have leaked out by now
that's basically because there would be
someone who refused to take the money
and they definitely would have went to
social media and told everyone about the
whole situation so yeah long story short
amazon didn't pay me this week so the
show was [ __ ]
sorry just getting that out of the way
bit of a runt but i do think the world
building and pacing of this one really
let it down and whereas we had lots of
scope and scale in the first two
episodes outside of numenor this was
pretty much just characters going
through dialogue and talking about the
world rather than having actual moments
i felt elrond in the dwarves were a big
miss and both aaron dear and the nori
stuff didn't really catch my interest so
that's the bad and now on to the good so
i'm trying to do negatives and positives
now as for the good i think hal branning
galadriel's story has been really
interesting especially with us starting
to learn more things about the men in
morgoth watching him play manipulate
people is a really clever character
trade as it makes you get swept up in
his charm without also realizing that
there's a darker side to it i think that
he's great to watch and if they do twist
him into a villain he'll become an even
stronger part of the series now if you
know what happens with numenor then
you'll know that's going to be a major
part of the series and judging by the
visuals and budget amazon do have the
money to pull it off again the visuals
are once more really good i do think
this is up there as being one of the
best looking tv shows of all time in
terms of the sets and cgi you compare it
to some other shows cgi at the moment
and it's night and day in terms of how
much better it looks so overall there's
your positives and your negatives and i
would say again that this episode was a
bit of a step down but i'm hoping that
now we know all the characters that we
can just hit the ground running next
week i don't think there's anyone left
to introduce unless we bring sauron into
the fold properly so maybe next time
i'll be a bit more enamored with it
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it in the comments below keep it
respectful please and understand that
people will have different opinions to
you i know it sounds crazy and it
doesn't mean that they're bots or shells
it they just might like the show you
know there's people who like sport but
some don't like rugby and some like
football you see what i'm saying mate
it's just a matter of taste
you get me i know you do you're a smart
kid anyway we are in a competition right
now and giving away three copies of top
gun maverick on the 15th of september
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
if that's you message me on twitter
heavy spoilers and some emails to watch
then make sure you check out our
brighton of house of the dragon which
will be linked on screen right now
you've gone over everything you need to
know about the latest entry and if you
haven't watched it get yourself over
there without the way thanks for sending
you the video i've been poor i'll see
you next time take care peace